[Music]
oh
here i am hello
how how are you gentlemen and gentle
women
yeah i didn't mean to show myself so
early this is awkward um
let me just start the game then
my day off today that i'm playing games
anyway crazy
i like the game i wanna
i wanna play
i'm excited to play some more
hopefully we're done with the prologue
and we can move on to the better stuff
i got a lot of comments that people are
fed up with the flu
which i don't get
it's beautiful i'll try i'll try to keep
it to a minimum
can't guarantee it though
i always forget how windy people are
until i do a playthrough
and i don't play the game perfectly
[Music]
everyone feels great to have you back
it's a big problem called kujira or
apparently the court figured it wasn't
safe in japanese waters
afraid some local fishermen might it's
[ __ ] gaming man
let's get it yeah
i don't know if i should listen to
people or just like do my own thing
because when i watch other people do
play-throughs it just looks so boring
it looks like they're trying way too
hard
we have fun here i
do at least
i already do this oh yeah i drove here
sorry
could we fire this pepe when streamers
eat on camera
um i want to go back to my house right
so i can get that uh sword [ __ ] melee
weapon vendor
why can't i just drive over there
i feel like i don't have that much money
but i really want a melee weapon right
should we check it out the [ __ ] is this
why is there a guy on oh oh he glitched
out oh no
oh
[Laughter]
bro jackie you're not supposed to be
on top of the car
ah what the [ __ ]
jackie no
my car is over there what is happening
i can't get there bro
i guess i have to do this first
dude this game is so buggy
it's crazy
[Music]
poor jackie he became a car it was
actually his dream
all along
it feels a bit like it has the skyrim
meme right
it's like it's such a fun universe that
it doesn't really matter
no one really cares
he waiting
all right wns let me loot yourself
54 even the pirate networks
you blowing up everywhere thank you i'm
i'm a big deal
yeah he's there dead
oh we were so close for a shower for
jackie
dead you got any notion of the [ __ ] you
pulled me into
but i didn't do it off the [ __ ]
emperor his
majesty anyone with so much as a piggy
toe dipped in this mess is as good as
dead
you're the one who got us into this mess
yeah let's start with your prep work
you had no idea sabre arisa could be at
the hotel
i don't have access to his personal
[ __ ] schedule and besides
nobody asks you to kill the old man that
wasn't
us this man's got a [ __ ] butt plug
bro explain this
i can't keep talking bro
all right settle down gotta be tactical
about this
parker ah then we
thank you go get yourself cleaned up
we're waiting for this finally
i get my own bathroom cringe
i'm not using your butt plug you sicko
[Music]
ah [ __ ] jesus smash the mirror
i don't know that's not really my style
but
we're there in this stoic play through
here
[Music]
they really want me to smash the mirror
all right huh i should have smashed the
mirror god [ __ ] damn it
i knew it
he i saw his butt plug remember our
first convo [ __ ] kill you
seems i've chosen the quiet life after
all
no blaze of glory for me
oh game over how about that well it was
a pretty good game
it was a little buggy but otherwise uh
not bad
all right we'll do it again and i'll
smash the mirror and then i'll live i
made the wrong choice there
so that's the prologue basically gotcha
so i just i just stopped playing last
live stream right before it
ended
which apparently no one ever did because
then they would have noticed that jackie
merches with the car
love like fire what up [ __ ]
[Music]
what happens in the mirror doesn't work
anymore
hey guys it's me keanu reeves
what are you saying you're amazing
no you're amazing
you're wondering where the [ __ ] did he
say i forgot tonight
[Applause]
you're breathtaking that's it
i thought he pulled out a gun
[Applause]
that's some big chunk of [ __ ] right
there
money's money can't [ __ ] around with it
you're wasting your lives
following us around like dogs what
curled up your ass
keanu's not into grippies huh
can you imagine all the [ __ ] rock stars
in the 70s and
80s and 60s did that today would just
like
completely ruin their career but back
then it was more
because they were just badasses for it
offer you one piece of advice for all
time's sake
stop being one time to bring on the
future
oh yeah
even looking back at it we're like yeah
rock stars are so cool but it's still
like
when you're mad
get in or change my mind
from the south yeehaw
get us in the air here put this on and
it
stays on got it
yeah i'm flossing so what huh
that's cool
abc's on the streets of watson sons of
[ __ ]
excuse me
collateral damage part of the plant too
chew it up there's so many references in
the game i wonder if they'll do a
john wick reference
thank you nightbot
target range of choir make it
i'm just here chilling
oh hell yeah thank you thanks thank you
thank you
i was not [ __ ] dead
probably take out the turret first right
we're just killing everyone it's
whatever
if i were them i would get off this
[ __ ] roof
okay done i could do
i could have zoomed in i didn't really
oh what the [ __ ] is that get the payload
on the elevator
arm it let gravity do its thing ah
i love gravity it's my favorite crumbles
yeah
i don't realize we play as key on it
this is amazing
[Music]
there's the stairs right there
i thought yeah i love the music and the
vibe of the game that's why i'm here
mainframe's not your playground murphy
come on evac announcement
broadcasting across all frequencies and
let's get moving
wrote this manifesto really need me to
answer that question
jesus johnny you've gone off the deep
end that's coming from a chair jock
come on hell yeah
oh finally headshots do something
oh hell yeah oh quick reload hell yeah
oh they had go boom boom
[ __ ] you oh thank you
[ __ ] yeah
bomb's name is what
[Music]
we watched that old nick cage shed
travolta classic yesterday uh face off
so [ __ ] good sorry
my bad i'm supposed to shoot that i
don't have my gun
not done yet still need to feed this to
their subnet
[Music]
press q what happens if i press q
quick melee
did her top just disappeared
no oh
yes
oh my god
oh it's up there
[Applause]
hell yeah this shit's what i'm talking
about
oh oh
stop moving
oh my god
so i have infinite ammo this is a
playing spray
[ __ ] closing in on the access point
they should have started the game with
this [ __ ]
sweet icebreaker foreign right
just wonder if we know anyone who could
switch the subnet protocol
hilarious right help or not
do spider spin webs it's time we caught
some flies
thanks murph now just for good measure
holy cyber cow we're on tv take a look
now to arasaka tower it's evacuation
ongoing after an unidentified terrorist
organization
released a manifesto yeah jackie snuff
it islands
rest in pieces quote unquote topple a
monument to corporate colonialism
night city's mayor emboli ebunike has
issued a statement declaring that he
will
bring the full force of the law to bear
in response to any act of terrorism
going now to our reporter on the scene
at arasaka tower
hopefully he can shed some light on the
situation as events
now get out of there
i know they went with japanese for the
aesthetic but it would make more sense
that it would be chinese right
should we jump down [ __ ] it i'm kiana
[ __ ] reeves [ __ ]
smooth i was supposed to go to the
[ __ ] rooftop i am so sorry damn it
whoa hey yo
yeah but japan is cooler i get
that's adam it oh [ __ ] adam smasher
we're fine
murphy what but it won't hold for long
run johnny like the wind what
i guess we made it out
they want to save the atom smash or boss
fight don't they
did they forget to make that part in the
game or what happened there
smasher told you johnny boy
told you i defend you someday um
pretty please
[Music]
no i know it's supposed to be that way
it's just kind of strange
are we back to our main character now
that was dope my favorite one that was
my favorite one so far
let us try once more you associates
who are they kiana reeves you won't
believe this
yeah he lives a double life this is
reddit legend but also
good cop over there all right we can say
something
which terrorist organization do you
belong to
how did you acquire fiscal material
ah
boss don't look too pleased with your
efforts
okay so this is before cool now we know
hot damn done and
gone whoa
my husband died in that tower
well cry me a river
but there are fates worse than death
oh [ __ ]
i didn't want him to die
nazi
[Music]
once i know japanese i'll have that
voice
no problem
transfer that's fine
go ahead
yeah i think that's the emperor right
okay
god they always do this [ __ ] thing in
games i don't know why
but we didn't hear anything about a big
explosion when we played it did we
depends how far how earlier how much
earlier this was
it's me surprise oh wow
shocked and you you who are you
who are you
john wick
uh
they just threw me in the trash
[ __ ]
dig yourself out why thank you gladly
now
it'd be nice yeah if they told you who
you're playing as
i guess we're back as
our main character because we don't have
the arm
detroit become human yeah it reminds me
of the trash scene too
i was literally thinking about it
guys please
so how long ago was the explosion
did they say it hey hey
oh [ __ ] heavier than he looks
now listen dawg i have done exactly what
you asked
so lest you and me figure this out whoa
you can put a butt plug there now sorry
i don't know why my brain went there i'm
sorry
oh it said it 52 years
wait that was present day 2023
explosion was in 20-23 what the [ __ ]
ooh love this car this is how tesla
needs to make them
thank you
so did they bring me back because they
think i'm the killer
you hear me i need your help
[Music]
hey
oh thank you
oh i love this gun [ __ ] it looks sick
all right shoot them oh wow it's all
wobbly
should i shoot the car [ __ ] does
nothing
they don't [ __ ] die
scripted event cringe
damn it looks sick though what
i don't take me out of it
i do no damage what
he just exploded randomly i didn't even
shoot him
whoa whoa oh
what the [ __ ] [ __ ]
whoa
uh if my vehicle takes damage what about
me
uh don't crawl on me please
ah it doesn't let me
i can't tell if i'm playing or not this
is so weird
that was way too scripted dan what the
[ __ ]
it's cool though
i did it yeah
okay i'll try but our car died
okay [ __ ]
oh now it works now the gun works cool
we both could use medical attention do
you know a repa doc
whom you can trust yeah
you you're
at kumpecki plaza we must get the
reputation
quickly hector
will fix us
up we have to get there somehow cause
someone
anyone all right all right all right
greetings my scanner indicates you are
outside the service area
just come pick me up i need to get to
misty's
esoterica front of fix
of course a vehicle is on route it
should arrive in less than 20 minutes
hey the personal link is damaged
do you think they'll make a br version
of this game below the ear
though not too deep there should be
auxiliary neurosockets between his lymph
nodes
beneath the scm muscle
now proceed to connect
i know that voice
i need to rest
me after a livestream
precious tanking it's neurogenic shock
he's dying gotta cut my way through the
occipital bone no other way
there is risk of i know what i'm doing
floor again hell yeah
the floor heals us as it should
oh god you're ugly imagine waking up
today
it's not clear why he's helping us
i'm not even sure he is helping us yet
how is he
maybe they want more answers out of me
on what happened
that's someone's mom
fee you in there ah
my head
how you feeling
i don't know vic here's a ring
and i'm seeing [ __ ] these
hallucinations describe them to me
blinding lights it's loud
i'm on stage and i almost can't breathe
i'm so damn full of hatred
that's a bit cringe
and i realized it didn't help i wrote
that [ __ ] i don't
feel any better no one talks like that
promise not to laugh oh okay i plan a
bomb an hour oh i got it sorry my bad
okay
they killed me vic never been so afraid
it was too real even for a lucid dream
it was all a dream dreaming v those were
memories
there's a personality construct on that
chart dreams you had
were from his past hang on
i mean to say there's an actual
terrorist in my head all right we got
the chip right
right now that's right johnny silverhand
at his crowning moment about 50 years
ago
ahq bombing heard of it
it's his doing people say he was buried
under the rubble
anyway that's not what's important right
now
think you can top the terrorist in my
brain
the biochip it's basically a bomb
fuse lit already you don't have much
time left
much life
a few weeks tops silver hands construct
is
overwriting your consciousness gradually
taking over your
body until one day you'll just be but
i'll become counter reeves
v it's important you get all this
you'll fix me up right vic
if i could i would be believe me
but this is it's way beyond what i know
how to do
you're the best of the best fig why
can't you help me
you want the long story or the short
i have to die i am going to die
that's what you're saying prove it
dex shot you right the bullet damaged
your chip slot
and your brain the biochip revived and
short-circuited you started uploading
data
into your head as far as it was
concerned
your brain was an empty vessel that
needed to be filled by the ingram it was
carrying
sure what but i'm right here
all of this is me
the shard doesn't read it writes
headache of yours
it's the bio chip rewiring your neural
path all right this is all a bunch of
mambo jumbo come on
doing away with the old
from where the shard's sitting you
what's left
is all a tumor that needs to be excised
can't we just take the chip out or
switch it off let me guess then i will
die
either way's out of the question you die
immediately
vic you've always come through for me
if there's nothing you can do to help me
then
well what the hell do i do tell me
please vic i wish i knew
kid
[Music]
misty
you're asking too much from an old-timer
like vic oh
[ __ ] misty ugh let's get you
missed hey 50 years
i'll be in your brain
i'll be taking over and he died
and i thought i was gonna die yes we're
back home excellent
with them in my sleep
sleep's a small hint of death
the inevitable can't actually tell if
i'm awake now
hell yeah we got our toes i could be
dead already right
oh that bed looks hella cozy focus on v
let it go here
got some meds for you omega blockers
taken regularly they'll keep things from
progressing too quickly
also they should keep that guest of
yours calm and quiet
pseudoendotrizine's from me effect will
be opposite
it'll speed things up free the demon so
i get a choice on which one i want
i gotta lie down is that a blue
blue and red pill reference
here now one more thing for you
vic pulled this out of your skull a
lucky charm
a [ __ ] oh it's a gun it's a bullet
promise you'll try to get some sleep
you're lovely
he had terrible taste in women
i'm so [ __ ] sorry jack's not here
anymore
jackie was special really spiritually
rich
he touched so many people with his love
don't worry he'll be around sure you'll
be all right
i'll be fine life is so beautifully
powerful
so much more powerful than death bro get
a haircut
please right now you need rest you look
like sleep
please sleep a floor mop i don't know
what is that
ah dude you're sleeping on the wrong
side
yo 72 xp let's go
all right so maybe now we get some more
choices to do side quests and stuff like
that
and more uh free roaming and and uh what
a what are not
out of here i
so he's not real he's just in our head
that's a little
i don't know why that's a little
disappointing maybe it'll be cool i
don't know
i don't smoke where'd you even come from
see we stepped the wrong way oh we're
even talking
[ __ ] should i know the [ __ ] kind of joy
toy are you supposed to be
[ __ ] ghost off
bro those boots gotta go talk to the
stranger i did that leave the apartment
nah
who you ah for start talking
[ __ ]
bro you're a ghost bro
[ __ ] chip
rip the thing out myself no wait
[Music]
hey
i'll take control i guess we'll split in
between us and [ __ ] like that
i'll find a way
you hear me
[Music]
smash
so
piano is kind of a dick see you never
[ __ ]
now like that oh some iron in your mouth
and pull the trigger
kiana reese's [ __ ] slap me our minds
touch us i'm like mold on fruit
creeping into you nothing i can do about
it
you hear me i'd puke if i [ __ ] could
it's just a copy of the engram i'm out
there somewhere
leave me alone get out just get the [ __ ]
out
the only thing that will fix this gotta
get hear me out a snack
a bullet to the [ __ ] brain
oh [ __ ] me
i hope he gets nicer i hope he gets a
little
we can get along ah yes showering with
clothes
i love it this is where you would see
your deck if you had the uncensored
version
man am i missing out
street cred baby
you hear that oh yeah
okay we're gonna stock up for sure
an old-ass burrito it can go to sleep at
home on tune
to pass time i can
shower if i want to let's get the
[ __ ] sword at last
so someone said there is there is a
sword in your
house i keep reading comments saying it
i just don't know where
where that gun is so good
um so these are in my storage right now
i feel like i might as well just
take them on me and sell them right no i
have too much stuff on me
that's why they went to the storage
gotcha
the guns are so [ __ ] cool the pistols
okay let's do that
so so where where would they be
uh yeah i have the blue ones and katana
is only green though
it's a bonus if you connect it to gog
really
well let's go do some side steps
we will just just not right now
why would i do that because i am the one
who saved your life
true i haven't managed to get my head
straight yet
not after everything that happened that
will not happen
anytime soon and so what
if you intend to leave you must re-enter
the ring
the bell has already told thomas diner
i am ready
oh he saw some stuff what is a [ __ ]
hammer
okay let's get rid of this [ __ ] that is
in blue
we getting any money for this yeah we
are
that one was kind of [ __ ] honestly sure
you want to sell this
because it's a quit doesn't matter
we can keep one assault rifle
these are the same
and then we keep the pistols because i
don't know which one is the good one
technically these do a lot more damage
shoddy's should i sell this stuff i
never
i really use it
definitely don't need the boots those do
look kind of cool though
i'll just sell the stuff that's cheap
right
pop turd how much are they five bucks
reduces web movement speed reduces why
would i use that
just scr scream at me if i'm doing
something terrible here because i i
honestly don't know
i just want to clear up
no one's screaming i'll take it
soy get the [ __ ] out of here
press j oh my god thank you
thank you okay
um we don't wanna we don't want any of
this right i mean that looks cool but i
want to get a
sword
i need more street cred for the katana
[ __ ] how much do i need
a legendary katana
twenty-five thousand i don't even have
the money
but there was a melee store around here
somewhere
let's go
try out freshly developed new tastes and
let your tongue be amazed
was reported slain on the premises of
the konpeki plaza corporate hotel
am i naked
what the [ __ ]
that's funny i didn't realize
i look sick i don't know i don't know
pants [ __ ]
come on ah [ __ ]
wait that covers up everything
all right today is a sad one in our
city's history
mayor lucius ryan has passed away
[Music]
so we have a bunch of side missions [ __ ]
no legs gang we're going there
that's what i want to do so it's what we
got damn gonna do
announced plans to run for mayor in the
upcoming election
today
all right give my goddamn vehicle
god damn it's so cool this area i'm
calling my car it doesn't work
i gotta hold it down it doesn't let me
why can't i get the car
is it because i'm tracking something
else
why can't i get my car
i'm holding it my car broke
so how do i get there
i sold my car key no
maybe i get maybe i get a car later
are you serious
can i steal someone's how do i get a car
i'll just get a car
here's a car right here perfect
okay maybe not that one here
uh excuse me
all right that'll do
don't don't shoot
can i hit these was easy who needs uh
he needs to own a vehicle you can just
pluck him from the trees
oh what the [ __ ] was that
probably should have stolen a better car
shouldn't i
[ __ ] piece of junk
i like the music though you have to make
a turn here
excuse me it's been a long time
yep okay the lady of westbrook estate
when you find the moment come see me we
must settle our accounts
for sandra dorsett you did quite well
you and that friend of yours until then
wasn't that a better looking car there
yeah that no way
[Music]
yeah yeah
this is what this guy was listening to
oops wrong way i followed the main quest
[Applause]
we wanted can't i just go down this
yeah excuse me guys
they're all driving the wrong way
[ __ ] idiots
[Applause]
[ __ ] it's like driving in real life i'm
like [ __ ] i missed the xc
god damn it all right no problem
yep this is how i drive no problem
you guys prefer third person
too bad i don't it's more immersive this
way
[Applause]
although the car stares like a
[ __ ]
bouncy car
[Music]
holy [ __ ] even in the future gps sucks
what the [ __ ] is this
ah [ __ ] hit me
you crazy could have gotten killed
all right so it's down here nice
almost there which way is it
is it in here yep
hello sword please
if you got in stock various items
if you are looking to cause pain
oh i am are you serious
[ __ ] has nothing better than
what i already had
i already had this don't i uh this is
more damage
oh we can get a katana let's go with the
katana then
yeah this place we can sell that
what are you buying
let's go
should we practice
i can't pull out my weapon here
[Music]
oh
h yeah yeah
yeah you like that yeah
yeah wait did i just see you a second
ago
okay nice a helmet
i'm gonna look cool
why
[ __ ] action blocked what
nazi
okay maybe i need to put away my
weapon why is this action blocked
strange
okay so let's pick a side
quest then we'll do moderate one to
start off
uh beat on the bright don't overthink
this one you have to defeat the champion
of kabuki nah
nah you got we got this tradition in
haywood on our 16th birthday
you your dad gives you a gun
birthday you your dad on your 16th
birthday you your dad
you your dad am i the dad am i stupid am
i reading this wrong we got service in
hayward on your sixth birthday you your
dad
gives you a gun you your dad gives you a
gun
on your six impressive you your dad
gives you a gun
what does that mean
he was like a father to me
it's a typo you're that no i don't think
it's a typo i think they meant to write
you your dad i am my own dad basically
i didn't get one because i had a shitty
day but you're way past your 16
aren't you high time to get yourself a
solid piece of iron
do they not have editors that check
check these
you you're dead
uh i don't want a gun so i don't i'm not
doing that
i don't know many rippers would install
kiroshi optics on credit and faith
in fact i only i only know one victor
maybe once you're on top you don't
forget about the old guy yeah pay the
man
no i don't have that money
i guess we'll do it
equip the p quick hack in your inventory
[ __ ] she must really like you essay
did i not do this
equip the ping quick hack in your
inventory
that's it right
i did and then i have this reset the
enemies optical cyberware rendering them
temporarily blind
okay i did it does that mean i get the
quest
all right let's just let's just do it i
need a car
mine out of the out of the vehicle sir
get the [ __ ] out i'm too weak can i
shoot him
i still can't take it
all right let's get this one get the
[ __ ] out
why the [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
[ __ ] cause it's mine hey you just shot
a man
careful [ __ ] crazy people out there
oh red light
i can make a right turn that's illegal
sheesh
why do i have zero health yeah uh
okay let's remove the [ __ ] bandages i
think that's what's [ __ ] me up
all right now we can equip the nope
i need to be level 10
i sold i sold all my pants bros i sold
all my pants
it's so fine
[ __ ] watch it
shortcut
euro truck simulator love it
would would i be dicks out right now if
i played the
nude version
whoa whoa
hell yeah right
are we going middle or up here okay
middle
amen
out of the way on break now [ __ ] it's
here
oh we're here nice
okay so the entrance in this is a bit
weird
it's like this yeah
yo we got a toothbrush
nice get really in there
open please thank you
i'm not buying it's an
um
what do you mean press tab i can hack in
of course
get some [ __ ] pants idiot
can't [ __ ] this up my whole life wrist
on it i thought i could go that way
[ __ ] [ __ ]
that's all right i got it i i got it
what
i i i
i don't get it how does this work
what the [ __ ]
so there and there is that it
oh my brain is so small it's shrinking
how many so i can only press a certain
amount of times
does it matter which order i press them
but i can 1c and then 54
i don't get it
yeah i see the needed codes but
i have to pick from the first one
and then i have to oh i can jump okay i
didn't realize i could jump them
i did it right
oh
am i missing a number
i know i need one c5 but it doesn't what
it doesn't
why did that work so it has to be in
that order
okay then i get it kind of
confusing
i felt my iq dropping by the second
there
now now
so looks like we found the last honest
cop all right give me a car
her name's anna hamill and whatever
she's investigating no more trucks
you hit
attached
[Music]
well this song sucks
thank you
i can get the witcher jacket what
sign me up now
bro i'm praying without pants i think
i'm okay
oh that's the police headquarters let's
not do anything
[ __ ] [ __ ] okay
sorry guys sorry about that
why i didn't do nothing
i did nothing
i'm innocent i'm 100 innocent
hey wait this is the main quest
uh i was actually can you can you wait
here i'm
i'm doing other missions
time for another rumble let's do that no
i don't want to do that
i thought you said the side quests were
good so far they're garbage
animals club sure
all right let's fast travel if you can
how do i fast travel
i can fast travel on the blue ones i can
fast travel there
no
i can't i need to go to a fast travel
point and
then fast travel to another one is that
how it works
well there's one uh right there
all right let's do that
are you what the [ __ ]
the [ __ ] kids
the [ __ ] out what do you think you are
huh
[Music]
huh you look [ __ ] huh how you think
you're tough
hi you think you're tough huh
yeah yeah go back to school [ __ ] go
back to school
go back to school [ __ ] yeah that's what
i thought
edit that out
okay
all right let's save some some time
yo burger burger
since we're gonna work together only
right now say hello no
no out out out don't [ __ ] hunt don't
hug introductions necessary
out
don't call the cops and breathe please
remember i i can't
while we're at it you need fresh wheels
bikes
yes yes so hit me up anytime all right
we'll do that after
[Applause]
holy [ __ ] i'm a shitty driver
the [ __ ] are you doing i'm driving here
whoa whoa how did i do that
ah
what the [ __ ] [ __ ] man i'm sorry
oh what
whoa whoa
[ __ ] man i just
reversed the car
[ __ ] there's a brawl happening on the
bridge
hey guys
oh yeah i have a serial health i forgot
well that was uh amazing
[Music]
what a [ __ ] playthrough it's a
learning curve hey this happens every
game
sure i might be a little slower but once
i get there
oh yeah
me her name's anna hamill and whatever
she's investigating
it's made her a lot of enemies she'd do
best to cut it out if you catch my drift
gotcha okay look i know how it sounds
but
somebody would have taken this gig
anyway right i don't know
maybe there's an angle god they're
really spamming me with a bunch of [ __ ]
okay so where i am i'm here
all right let's [ __ ] go here
either way info is attached
stop calling me i'm busy
introducing a deadbeat with a
pretentious name
girl broke my trust and skip town what
are you talking about [ __ ] him
only thing i care about now is the day
that he left an nc
oh was i not supposed to be here
[ __ ] all right it's katana time perfect
oh
oh baby
oh nice
they're upstairs
what the [ __ ] did you say daniela
where are they
where are they huh
where the [ __ ] are they
don't shoot swedish [ __ ]
i didn't have to do that but it felt
good
where are they above me
[Music]
oh they're in here no
i really need to get that [ __ ]
hacking thing
how are we doing here lady
what's the thing i need here
some shards you find in the world
containing information hidden behind
encrypted okay i gotta crack it
but i gotta find her laptop
crime who reporter ratted me out
she was already dead dude
yeah on the main map it shows the pad
yeah but i thought
must be absurd or downstairs
i only want to talk promise
you lied he [ __ ] he lied he made the
lie
[ __ ] love the sword man we made the
right call boys
and girls
the legless samurai continues
hey where'd you come from it was just
downstairs
you want to talk about this i
don't know what you saw there i just
don't go down there
i don't know anything they forced me
i'm there hostage said if i try to
escape
i'd be next on the table i swear
it's your right not to believe me you
also have to write to a discount oh
the discount did someone say discount
special prices for special customers
thank you mm-hmm in exchange for getting
what i saw in the basement
yes well but well said
deal sure deal basement's already
forgotten
perfect glad to agree please let me know
if you need anything
well i do what kind of stuff you got oh
okay legs legs
legs i need some more street cred [ __ ]
one day guys one day
i need more i need to level up my
intelligence
i can get uh eight percent resistance
seems pretty good
i can get a new bone
creases out by 20 yeah
yeah give me bones
i don't have the money ain't got the
funds
all right so we got 20 more percent more
cap and
have i forgot to level up or something
let's level up intelligence
uh unlocks mass vulnerability demon
which reduces the physical resistance
for all enemies in the network
all right that's pretty good
disabling all cameras since we're good
let's go with that for now
that's quick hacking too
all right we have seven in now too bad i
already bought everything
oh you're just gonna okay
that's a car right here
what are you gonna do what are you gonna
do
i've been infected with poor
there's a purple drop in that basement
all right we'll go back
i just gotta do this
how do i switch camera again cue
i wonder how that backing up thing did
so much damage
holy [ __ ] like how did i [ __ ] that car
up so much
oh no oh no
let me go i'm doing you a favor bladey
all right maybe not
bro nice knees
would be a shame if something happened
to them
all right let's get going
[Music]
nice
why me
[Music]
wait where was the shop again it's one
of these side streets
[ __ ] i'm lost where was it i remember
driving here
okay i'll do jacket side quests chill
chill chill
you can enter here right
should i at least be able to
here it was here all right there better
be a purple item
where that was it all right where we got
what the [ __ ] is that incendiary round
i'll take that [ __ ] oh there it is
okay oh
okay okay okay girl
okay
thanks guys
so which one did you say i should do
with the
bike
hello
i have to call mama wells
bro i'm so broke
[Music]
be good to hear you
finally been a long time since we talked
since when jackie passed away
thank you calling to
offer my condolences
offer your condolences
you lived under a roof have the decency
not to treat me like some stranger you
just
just give me the bike i was going to
call you i prepared an offender
we can't let him go without a proper
goodbye the ceremony will be at the
coyote
many of his friends will be there
say no more mama wells i'll be there
i did not doubt it for a second
okay heroes boom
how far is that
pretty far
we actually up here i don't remember
going here
all right we need a ride stop stop
stop
thank you
oh i like this car
[Music]
oh it's fast car i like it
hell yeah hey watch out
some people just don't watch the road
[Music]
utopia night city you're so eager for
four years if you say so
what is happening play it
[Music]
all right i can sing instead
[Applause]
[Music]
oh here we go
skirt skirt on this [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
no no idiot [ __ ] god damn it
it wasn't me it wasn't me
it wasn't me
i didn't do anything y'all saw that that
was not my fault
can you zoom out the minimap
[Music]
nice to meet you i like people who
understand value of respect
[Music]
it tells me to go left right [ __ ]
last second dude
[ __ ] don't stand on the street like
morons god
a little a little bright cheese
[Music]
clean clean
el coyote cocoa
yeah we got to get rid of it
really he's pretty massive give me the
bike
the nice to see you give me
the bike okay sit sit
you want a beer i want the bike you know
what god damn well i went here no thanks
i'm good i'm doing a no alcohol
playthrough
the bike please a lot of time has passed
how you been
hanging in there somehow [ __ ] i gotta
pee somehow
you could have come over for dinner
see they do that thing they mix spanish
and english stop it
i am in the middle of preparing an
ofrenda there is
still so much to take care of want to
take part in the ceremony
i got to pee i gotta i'm dying i want to
do it the right way
in line with tradition
but something i'd lay by his casket
that'd do
justice to his memory
i don't got anything but your heart is
in the right place
don't worry he's symbolic
look for something in his garage his
past is all there
are you getting enough sleep
you
what's wrong
so
are you getting enough sleep
what's wrong
thanks mama oh i got the car ah don't
touch it
you have respect i admire that
the garage is on republic
what do we got
[Music]
ivy what are you doing here sitting and
waiting
and yeah waiting for him though i know
he's never coming back
lately i've just been coming here to sit
an hour
sometimes too i know it's gunk it's just
i miss him a lot
hardly gone
there's a huge chunk of his past in
there
am i giving me a hand i'm not sure i
should go in there v
still too soon she's so annoying no it's
not that
mama wells that's not a door exactly on
the best terms
she wouldn't want me touching any of his
things disturbing the memory
that i know jackie would want you here
that's more important come on
thank you i just won the car i don't
want to hear her mope about her
boyfriend
if that was real life i would have done
this exact same thing
it's a fine piece of metal and mechanics
he was so psyched
locked i wonder what's in there
that's his lair slept there he must have
had a different key
let's look around might be tucked away
somewhere
still full his favorite kind of
strategic reserve oh hell yeah i want
his garage
guess no man cave is complete without
some of those huh
he said they're collectibles they don't
print them anymore
that's definitely why they're up there
yeah
does it bother you that i cut her
dialogue
oh jackie mandela
it's a long story
hey you all right
i won't i will never cut main quest
stuff but side quest and i
hate her i can't do it better than all
right
i once told jackie he should sweep all
the dark energy out of this place
a sand mandala do the trick for example
he told me that out of sand he'd build a
castle
a home the wells family hideout
stronghold
something i guess you made a bigger
impression than you thought
oh you got a sniper later
it's beautiful it's hideous
but it's also the most beautiful thing
i've ever seen
choose an offering
an aquarium they used to be tacos
and taco was
miss fish minnie
sounds like a mighty expensive fish
oh i don't think he bought it
okay i gotta choose an offering to that
a friend though
but how
leather belt sort of a
memento oh that's perfect his dad's he
used to beat both jackie and his mom
with it
oh until one day jackie fought back
kicked his butt told him he'd kill him
next time
old man was hospitalized and then he
left
why'd he hold on to it in case his dad
ever comes back
true memento this perfect
well you got something for your refrenda
but we could look around a little more
i think i'm good
love to poke around engines he was 15
when he first got on a bike
knowing him it's a miracle he never
wiped out
got to be hanging here since 2020 2020
basketball signed by dante gonzalo oh
[ __ ] dante
he was from haywood too everyone here
shot hoops
dante ran circles around him i think he
might have been the first kid to ditch
the valentinos
like jackie they both
wanted more out of life dante's captain
of the nc blackouts now
better get going actually via
i think i'll stay a while say bye to him
here
mama wells wouldn't want me there anyway
i understand take care of yourself misty
yeah u2v
this is like the shittiest hey
everything okay romance of all times
yeah
i just need some time i just don't see
them together at
all
all right howdy
what now i'm just uh
checking you out
it was a fine boy then go raise a glass
to him padre
a few glasses
it's good you're here yeah we're about
to start it was like a father to me sit
down
please baby i
came in with our pants
[Music]
i thank you all for coming today
i'm not going to tell you what kind of
man my son was
or lament about how much i miss him he's
dead
can we go into his funeral just hoping
we get his bike
when he was about 19 years old
jackie was in the valentinos they were
at war with miles from back then
i get a call from the hospital
they tell me always rest the occasion
i'll wait three times
just by the heart he was conscious when
i get there
so many tubes coming out of him
he looked like a like a pulp like an
octopus
or something he tell me
he said
look i'm bulletproof nothing bad will
ever happen to me
and when i go he take off his
valentino's ring
he swear he won't need it anymore
but he was not scared
he just didn't want me to worry
this gun pass
hey doc is here among the membership of
the night city devil's boxing club
we have this saying make your best
friends among the fighters who knock you
out cold
and it's true jackie czar was a cannon
no one's ever hit me as hard i can still
almost feel it
12 rounds buddy
where's the f4 respect button come on
anyone else me me
i uh i often
think back to the first time me and jack
met
two days ago i hired to drive him and
some contraband
across the border he bought some goods
clepped from arasaka
top secret priceless
a lizard and uh
i remember what he said then
that i came from a place where
everyone's family
[Music]
so he must be too jackie
wells
best friend you could ask for loyal to a
fault
once he set his mind to something you
must be wondering why i'm not wearing
any pants
he's ready to die to achieve it well
jackie hey the painting just told me
brodar broder the one thing we can't do
is be afraid of others
[Music]
for his loved ones he'd sacrifice his
life without hesitation but most
importantly
he had no pains jackie loved life and
had no fear
hard on his sleeve he didn't overthink
things he just
went for it thought he was bulletproof
and that he became legend at the
afterlife
and ultimately he did what he set out to
do
[ __ ] in the shoes of some powerful
people
and if he's watching i bet just about
now
he's flipping him all the birds not a
bad speech
he feared no one and wasn't afraid and
here's the belt his dad live life
beat him with yeah oh that's a nice
guitar
i would like to say a toast
for jackie
thank you for your kind words i'm glad
you're here
it was a beautiful friend that we gave
him you know what
you're a good man i know jackie would
want you to have this
for for me it's for me
uh i mean i can't accept this
really are you getting enough sleep uh
but i mean if you insist
i thank you
[Laughter]
it's mine what the [ __ ] hey you have a
drink with us
nice mustard wells
how'd you meet jackie we started out
together
in the valentinos no in the [ __ ]
bible book club oh hell yeah
i got only good memories of him
rest easy up there brother
i have to keep talking to him i think we
might know each other
v yeah i've heard about you
well heartfelt condolences friend
from me campo and all the valentinos
thank you all right
why not to wells
may he rest in peace go for now
thanks for you another
i already do
me too cabron me too
here's to jackie got off to greener
pastures
jackie [ __ ] it i'll drink for jackie
there's nothing in it a proud son of
haywood
look away children
well uh i should mingle vic all right
let's get the [ __ ] out
see you later
yeah we got a [ __ ]
sword and now we have a bike give me the
bike give me the bike
yes yes it's mine where is it
where the [ __ ] is it where's the bike
where oh it's over here
oh you can slide and [ __ ]
[ __ ]
yeah baby
[Music]
[ __ ]
god damn it let's try that again
there she is mama
a mommy
[ __ ] yeah [ __ ] yeah
yeah [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
watch it
yeah [ __ ] stay the [ __ ] down
i'm not doing anything oh my god
why do i die in one shot it's ridiculous
[Music]
i didn't do nothing
all right i'll stop [ __ ] around
my bad hombres
okay is there anything else we want to
do
nah don't need to do that anymore
should we try this it's difficult
that's that's just a random quest okay
this is a random ass quest
should we try the animals club
you guys want to do the main quest
main quest might be time all right
should probably fast let's just fast
travel there
i know we have the bike but there's one
right here
yep
i wish i i wish i wish it uh had
a little bit of that vaporware
soundtrack as well
at least in the loading screens or
something
all i wanna do is anna
bro we're doing a pant less run never
heard of it
special achievement in the end all right
mate thanks for waiting
sit you do not
look so bad ah thank you then
in the car i doubt it you would survive
oh
thank you the [ __ ] is that kid looking
at
stop staring at me [ __ ]
what do you actually want from me
to begin you must tell me where to find
evelyn parker evelyn what she do
she and yorino barasaka had intimate
relations
she knows how to get to him i've been
thinking i would have a word with her
myself
she promised to help me get rid of the
chip i would not count on that
she's likely gone very far away
just answered your own question about
where evelyn is
long gone why do you believe
she could help you remove the chip does
a cooperation help her
suspect so yeah hold up
evelyn was knowledgeable about the relic
had a large chunk of classified info
an enigma to be sure but she showed that
slimyness he getting corporal agents
you know kind i do possess this slide as
you speak of
you got tossed out lumped with the
outcasts easily
or have you forgotten
is that all really should be going
wait
must answer for this crime bomb
patricide
looking for justice in night city i
seek revenge much more feasible here
i have allies prepared to bring
ryorinovo to his knees
the only thing i need is proof and you
think
they'll trust the word of a merc i have
nothing better now
also i know no one here
and i am a fugitive hell yeah i am hot
but seriously they said it so what we
stroll into arasaka hq and announce that
yorinobu is a kin-killer
that he murdered sabro will get the
hearing before reasonable people
in a neutral location certain
procedures will be used to establish the
truth
a lie detector forget it
in that case another option i like the
yakuza reference
you are dying the full tattoo but i
don't know how to save yourself
cyberpunk [ __ ] instead that's cool the
relic
is a culprit technology made by
arasaka technology they alone know
this cooperation can save you as easily
as it can make you disappear
it is merely about getting the right
people on your side
politics you mean people like anders
hellmann
you know this name how prepped for the
heist you're really savoring that burger
aren't you
hellman's design his creation and true
he's a pawn i was thinking of one much
more powerful he's got a mic in that
burger guys
helmet escaped arasaka betrayed
finish the burger
no that's how i speak japanese
[ __ ] soccer scums everywhere what a
[ __ ] hey
i was listening to that shut up nobody
except you wants to watch that [ __ ]
about that corpo [ __ ]
what did you say you heard me let it go
takamura
bro you don't make out with a burger you
eat it
thanks for the offer need to think about
it
get back to you is he eating the inside
inside of the burger and keeping the
shell to plan
organize you stand to gain much if you
help me
all i ask is that you do not leave the
city
leave why would i leave need help
best chance i'll find the right person
here someone other than arasaka
specialists
there's no one no alternative
actually we just talked about some
with a bit of luck i'll track down
evelyn
if she could not help you before she
will not
manage to dao honor among thieves
ever heard of it he's just [ __ ]
smelling it i thought it ironic
thieves have that there's just honor
i believe your noble arasaka would agree
i'm sure that's the third time she comes
over
why i would think about the plan b
anders hellman he invented the relic
if i want to get rid of it he's my man
and if that means picking another fight
with arasaka so be
it hellman defected from the company
i myself spent many days looking for him
he what's the expression
dropped off the face of the earth
why are you looking for a helmet he was
the one to alert sabrosan to yorinobu's
schemes
he knew both of them well and could be
an important
witness corporal rats will squeal when
hanging by their tails
for several days i collected the
information
always point to one place the club
called
the afterlife i was quickly
dismissed by the queen of fixers there
rogue
she take you for a suit no she saw me as
sabrosa's killer
rogue's well informed gets wind of most
things that happen in the city
it might be worth asking her about
helmut i wish you luck
dolma is choosy expensive and rude
god they don't really keep it concise do
they i cannot stay here
any longer do what you want look for
parker
hellman forever i must see some friends
calling some favors when my people in
arasaka are ready to listen
i will call you till then i guess
you buy some miracle you'll find hellman
please notify me he and i have
unfinished the business
oh look char blossom
zapper what filth in some ways night
city never changes
our sock is still a despotic machine in
the world's on a collision
course with chaos but hey at least
rogue's still alive we're buddies now
you got some nerve
yeah first you had to kill me now you
want to be my pal
make like nothing happened you know you
don't gotta speak out loud to talk to me
yeah the guy that's eating a burger for
15 minutes might
think i'm weird anymore
go [ __ ] yourself dick wipe hey
wasn't easy for me either you woke up in
a landfill i woke up in your head
wrestling with your thoughts memories
think we're even
and i've taken a step back looked at
things
think we might be able to help each
other we could start with rogue
her and i go back to the stone age it's
a main quest how did i realize this
[ __ ] guy
it's so distracting you're the ghost of
christmas past [ __ ]
any friends you had are either dead or
so old their memory's gone
johnny silverhand died a legend nobody
forgets that
so you [ __ ] know rogue what do i say
to her
got a talking brain tumor claims it's
her old friend johnny
trust me rogues heard dumber [ __ ] than
that way back when you weren't even an
itch in your daddy's ball sack don't
need convincing
seeing your memories growth
roguel danced any tune i play or just
get yes
oh hell yeah oh we're done
we're finally done can i pull my gun out
burger
look at my [ __ ] leg look at that
[ __ ] leg
you will finish that burger
very well he's a tough one
i don't recognize you just passing
through
yes and i'll be leaving as soon as he
finishes
bro you're sucking on it you're not
burger king but like the last thing you
want in your burgers counter race foot
fungus
[Music]
all right
so we should upgrade body right because
then we can
oh i can't
outside of convex
stamina might be good health bar is good
too
i don't have any i don't know why i
thought i had perk points
okay so we are just supposed to call
judy and that's it
you can't call while you're on the bike
damn i love the look of this gun
this one not so much
listen need to find evelyn i really
don't want to talk about her
you know where she is what'd i just say
drop it i won't tell it again
can we meet let's meet please
you out lizzy's what
what
sorry i'll get out of your way
oops
doesn't steer much this
ah
[Music]
is there no way to zoom out the minimum
jesus whoa
that's right i can walk
let me in hey haven't i seen you here
before
yes let me in
got a good memory for faces let me in
we're closed right now let me in need to
talk to punching judy
she and her dead yep
take the stairs down thank you
how's it going honeybun whoa
whoa start again what is it
why am i so slow now judy is
embarrassing herself hey
where are you going nothing to
judy's sleep
stop telling every joy toy you need to
come here the hell i'm supposed to do
with them all
you're so concerned about strays go take
care of your guests
zeus we're not done here oh yeah we
[ __ ] are
all right we're done
you just don't give up do you this is
nothing more to say
you've seen evelyn i thought i made that
need to talk to him uh it's important
why so you can make her your escape goat
for your train wreck of a heist
seem to know how the heist went meaning
you did talk to her
i know how you [ __ ] up got all your
doombath killed
like a real pro
caught some lead myself too
boo hoo occupational hazard for you
mercs
sure i took a risk we all did but it was
evelyn who gave it to us in the first
place she knew what this was from the
start
hello fine
looks like we're all in this piss pot
together
speaking of piss you're desperate
writing's on your face
okay let's just say i'm pretty much
[ __ ]
biochippy clef during the heist is
killing me
albeit slowly evie commissioned the job
i know how to stop that that's why i
need to know who hired her
let's say i believe you
all right evelyn's a doll used to work
at clouds
i'd look for her there where is that
sid case on my table's got the address
take it
and once you find evelyn give it to her
thank you mega tower luxurious
wait
um just let me know how she's doing
okay
[Music]
forget evelyn admit it this is about
judy's virtues
good [ __ ] if i say so myself
[Music]
call me mr hands nice hands bro you're
looking for pacifica jobs call me
okay name's me what no
please dimitris i'm
truly honored to meet you if you've got
any biz
call me whoa
what the [ __ ] i could get killed
that's what i'm talking about
perfect driver see this [ __ ]
told you bro i told you i'm about to
driving bro
just as planned
[Music]
thank you
way i see the only thing waiting for you
here is getting off
or getting off place your bench
rebounding from the crisis
i missed this time enlighten me
brain dance chick is hiding something no
coincidence we already saw
two tiger claws they must control the
building
i think judy's lying why
little something called intuition ever
heard of it
oh so what you meant to say was you're
full of [ __ ]
this game is nuts dude
what the [ __ ] is going on did it get
dark
he's on your doorstep
[ __ ] is oh it's a hologram cool
welcome to clouds where we know what
you're looking for
would you care to jack into the terminal
you realize personal links aren't secure
right
we need data from your core meaning the
biomed
just that click the wrong thing all
right let's do this
this will be a live session so events
may take an unexpected turn
but don't quit if you feel uncomfortable
you could miss out on something truly
remarkable
[Music]
if you feel unready to handle what comes
next you can interrupt the session
immediately
and saved
now bear with me a moment scanning your
personal profile we're gonna do
oh no we're doing close your eyes kids
please close their eyes
and ears close them now oh god what do i
get
oh god oh no who am i matching
please not angel what the [ __ ] is this
what is this interesting
is that normal or who can say what is
normal you're clearly a unique person
with
unique tastes our system can handle it
so who will it be angel or scott [ __ ]
angel
skye gotta go with sky i couldn't have
chosen
better myself well you couldn't because
you didn't now for the payment
and you'll venture into the cloud uh
right
uh jack out i don't want to pay i'll pay
there you go 50 bucks after pocket
what and the payments come through
so the entire floor is open to you
if you wish to wind down first
skye awaits you in booth nine
disconnect please is that it
and we have a strict no weapons policy
here at cloud oh
please deposit any and all hazardous
items with me i'm not i'm not packing
bruh don't worry i'm not packing two
willing to spread their legs
we hope you enjoy your show
hey hey hey hey hey hey
oh yes vincent uh
oh i i'm i'm a virgin
it's just v v just v
only people who know me real well can
use my real name don't tell mercia
okay then fee i'm married
uh uh
welp looks like this will be interesting
i should have picked angel [ __ ] you're
dying
samurai samurai
oh what's going on [ __ ] this goddamn
thing threw me out yeah need to talk to
you
talk you pulled the emergency brake
ripped me out just to talk yes what
happened
i'm married not interested and frankly
you're not that attractive evelyn parker
what do you know about her
not much everyone's got their own booths
their own problems their own little
bubbles
that's a fragile ecosystem
people like you bargin violate it
try to rearrange no
i ain't paying her [ __ ]
answer the question do it and then you
can get back to whatever it is you do
here's what i don't do spill to any
rando who walks in here
how about those good looks of yours be
shame if they dip below club standards
anything out of the ordinary happened
here lately
fine it worked heard a customer did a
number on her
guys don't be horny [ __ ] all right
coomer's gets back the [ __ ] out is
around here way more often than anybody
care to admit
you ought to ask tom two of them were
inseparable gossiping for hours on end
who's tom a doll
like the rest of us what do you think an
xbd star
will i find him vip area
booth too i think thanks
see you turned out to be useful after
all
yeah we did it
coomer free playthrough
nice i can't get in what's that mean
i'm here every [ __ ] week you're
not authorized to access the vip area
there's a vip area
what the [ __ ] did i do
what
[Music]
you could you you could die what the
[ __ ]
it's restricted area i was in vip huh
but what if i want to vip
i can't get in what's that mean i'm here
every [ __ ] week you're not
authorized to access the vip area oh yes
i
am just paul you can take it off
he saw me
stop stop that
stop it
okay thank you
oh
[Music]
okay all right
just gonna have a little snack for later
keep him nice and cool
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ]
smart glass
deactivate
they can't oh they can shoot they can
shoot
sneak 100
that's right i don't know what i know
what i'm doing
[ __ ]
sorry i know
part of the plan part of the plan
all right how how is the gun is the gun
i got any good
it's a [ __ ] sponge dude
let's kick it in
[ __ ]
what's [ __ ] up
[Music]
that's a cool weapon
so
too smart for this game
all right maybe we should shoot this guy
maybe not like this god
last last sabaroo
is he okay is you okay
oh
okay okay
where is it
what am i there we go [ __ ] i thought i
took it already
[Music]
no it's not right what am i missing here
what do you want don't shoot me shut up
and pull yourself together
you've got me confused with someone else
i've never seen you in my life
i couldn't have done anything i need to
ask you a question so shut up
and listen looking for evelyn parker
evelyn no idea what she's been up to not
[ __ ] around drop the act i know your
friends tell me where she is
uh woodman told me she up and vanished
woodman who's he mr forrest
but we all call him woodman never really
known where will i find him
back office he almost never leaves hey
it's like me
okay i don't know anything i swear
now where were we
oh yeah
that's good
it's kind of hard to orient
or navigate
who are you what do you want
i'm gonna ask the questions drop your
iron and start talking
just stay on point and i said
drop it i'm not dropping
anything
is that a boss fight
well aren't you the king
now what too bad you can't talk to dead
people
oh wait you're doing it now anyway
just scour is gone that just might work
nice cool
we got a new gun purple
[ __ ] purple gun let's try it
out
oh what up you scared me kiana
[Laughter]
foreign
this way
[Music]
door
did i miss something obvious
sold her off to a ripper ship was busted
go to center to get it patched up a
river named
fingers in a back alley for hookers
sounds like a joy toys wet dream
oh we level up nice
finally
[Music]
don't shoot don't shoot swedish
i thought you was a dead man
nice time to bounce oh [ __ ]
no hell you don't
oh it's a [ __ ] brute
oh
okay
nice
i'm required to return your weapons hey
i don't know anything i just work here
hey i don't know anything i just work
here
no witnesses
nice work back there thanks man ever
thought of applying for the diplomatic
core
[Music]
[ __ ]
fingers got it i think we'll find her
there v if i could see that far
i wouldn't be a [ __ ] ghost on a chip
in a corpse's head right now
i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry
no don't shoot i'm a police officer of
the law
i didn't do anything stop snitching
stop snitching
got shot what the [ __ ] they're in here
[Music]
we're cool right
it's gonna sit here
meditate
nice thanks i deserve that
no worries you can rely on me
i'm pewdiepie i'm a good guy
i'll let people live i'll let all of you
don't waste your life you think fingers
got her
i think we'll find her there v if i
could see that far i wouldn't be a
[ __ ]
ghost on a chip in a corpse's head right
now
you think fingers got her i think we'll
find her there v
if i could see that far i wouldn't be a
[ __ ] ghost on a chip in a corpse's
head right now
no i got that don't have time to massage
egos
i respect that of course you do
damn we got a lot of items for that bomb
in this place no need to go so ott
i've got other methods one thing's for
sure though the claws won't forget this
are the cops
we got some good ass [ __ ]
oh mods
um should we up our intelligence
or blades and presents nothing
dodging recovers stamina
yeah let's do that let's
up our body as well
excuse me that's normal trust me it's
normal
you had a plan you tried it fell flat
no no damn it jesus the [ __ ] do you want
from me
code's still going in 2077. [ __ ] it's
all
going too slow gonna decommission before
we learn how to rip the chip out
yeah let me alone to sell yourself to
the sakas
they'll end you one is dead said so
yourself
made it pretty clear since that i
changed my mind
want you to live now i asked you already
what the hell you want from me i gotta
get out of jail free card
i'd be a [ __ ] fool not to take
advantage
see me in our osaka we got a half
century old score
neat settling and i plan to do it
that's what i need you for
never been recruited into a terrorist
cell before
listen honestly i know thanks where we
can save your life
who can help us do that
you'll get rid of the chip i'll smash
soccer
win win kid soul killer is what we need
and mikoshi's how we grab it
okay so this mikoshi
what is it exactly
am i high you all see that went so far
sure that's how you became a construct
exactly now mikoshi's the place soul
killer operates out of
where it stores its victims and grams
yes still don't see how mikoshi's linked
to my chip problem
not the brightest bulb on stage are you
50 years back alps on the human mind
mikoshi was the sole place on earth
where they did anything
like that
bet it still is today he's so hard he
double smokes
it's where we'll settle our biz you
yours
me mine
[Music]
and uh how you plan to smash our socket
this time
got another nuke tucked away this time
bombs named alt
cunningham i'm supposed to know who that
is
not yet but you will once we find what
we need
for now we got no time to lose need to
get inside makoshi
it's so cool how keanu reeves is in this
game i [ __ ] love that
it could have picked a better person for
the job
[Music]
so [ __ ] cool too god damn
look at this [ __ ]
and jesus
all right it's only 125
sorry for my uh trigger finger there
i'll keep it cool from now on i just get
too worked up you know
[ __ ] off
hey not one step closer here to see
who
we can use this option now got an issue
needs sorting out
you're to do that so how about you [ __ ]
off
let me through and no one will be the
wiser
so serious from the get-go i was only
joking
sheesh fine let him through sludge
that's what i thought
that's what i [ __ ] thought
hostile area is that uh
is that
she [ __ ] went through me dude i don't
owe you [ __ ]
open i made it all the way here huh
not really messing around what the hell
what the what the [ __ ] are you
den in pacifica sit in wait your turn
got a couple of questions quick you
answer quick will leave you to get back
to your patience
logical through and through impossible
to argue with
your job bro
i ain't putting you see oh here
is likely to feel ever so slightly
awkward
if i leave half her face off
looking for a girl named evelyn parker i
know she came here what
clinic yes but i have a procedure i must
finish
may i no you can go back and play doctor
once you're done with us
i didn't say anything about putting
anything anywhere i'm just saying
circumstance is what they are my [ __ ]
i can't wait
they're there wipe away your tears
don't want any short-circuiting now do
we
you tiger claws far as i know i'm all
paid up
we're with the marks
the mocks why didn't you say so
so what brings you here
i used to ride a nomads resource of folk
wouldn't cast anything aside until it
was worn down dead
couldn't be fixed or reused in some
other way but where you're giving these
girls
not even nomads would touch that
please let's not exaggerate
i give them what i can you're looking
for a
friend already told you
i'm looking for a woman named evelyn
parker need to know where she is
step into my office please many girls
come through here
so many but let me put it to you this
way
i believe in giving each of them the
personal
touch ask anyone
i'm more than a chop doc
see i know what people truly want a
hairline
to be flattered praised
padded to feel like
like this i'll be more than glad to show
it of course
i can suggest you start remembering all
you can either that
or i'll make sure you never forget my
face two
beefers from a bd studio took her didn't
even know their names
they mentioned the moth of all things
virtues with the death's head
said she'd be good for the moth one more
time please yes
what did i need
oops i'll be outside
is he okay bro
you okay bro
did he
hey 50 bucks nice
oh you're [ __ ]
oh that's all right that's right we'll
get rid of the evidence
we'll get rid of the evidence
can i use it
just gotta get rid of the evidence
[Music]
sorry i'm getting rid of the evidence
could have stopped but i didn't
police on the ground he fell on the
chair
he fell in the wheel bro seriously
ice where the [ __ ] is he shooting me
from i'm dead now
i was getting rid of the evidence [ __ ]
losing our cool won't do us any favors
it's a waste of time
oh i'm cool real [ __ ] cool with the
fact that ebb's probably already dead
you don't know that it was an accident
and i'm sure as hell not gonna squander
precious minutes we could spend
looking only leave we got's an xbd
where does that get us we also know
we're looking for something related to
the debt's head
that's better nothing i don't get your
optimism
still sounds like a big fat nothing to
me
need to figure out where they're
scrolling this stuff might be a rat hole
of some sort
doubt they do much shooting on location
yeah
the girl is left without a jaw [ __ ]
you're right
it could be we'll see something to point
us in their direction and one of their
virtues
ugh have to be real gonks to leave a
clue
we don't leave any traits behind
everything leave something behind
just need to know where to look lucky
for me
i'm running around with the best bd
specialist in town
has an extra pair of expert eyes well
your bd expert has a better idea
pleasures of knight bdd
a domain with its twin on the dark net
every kind of thing goes on there they
disappeared on something useful
nothing happened
let me think for a sec ah what a tragedy
did you see this
you must have fallen in the chair that's
crazy
i think i've got a better idea that's i
saw a smut shop on jig jig street
all kinds of stuff there thank you
you don't even care she doesn't even
care meantime see if i can't find
something on the ncp domain
i'll wait in the van all right i'll
report to the authorities what happened
here
there will be justice for hair guy
draw guy dentist guy i don't know
hey yo man you trying to rip us off i
got four bags missing here
that's the cut i got off pablo don't
like it take it up with him
i ain't dealing with pablo i'm dealing
with you that means you and me got a
problem
now i could paint the sidewalk with your
guts but that wouldn't get me what i'm
old
oh you want to try go on son
oh [ __ ] bruh
hey you hear me loud and clear you don't
need to yell
what's up just kill them cold-blooded
you know over here yeah that didn't make
sense
i didn't think big parties were here
something that will keep you yeah
wow you know running low on heads
gotta bring in the clients attract them
and [ __ ] i can't do that could try
selling iron straight from the factory
skip the whole part where you tinker for
hours on each little shooter what's this
one
my dignity tweet ah why
sure i'm in holy [ __ ] well
uh how can i be right now we'll wait on
you see
that's awesome thank you cd probably red
can't believe it
brofist everywhere and a shark tooth
that's so cool
we're looking for uh something special
a brain dance to really what's up huh
you mean
is that a no pp pump hardcore
a lawyer infuser but there's a guy on
jig
street has a whole lot of peculiar
flicks and i mean
peculiar
looking for uh something special oh my
god i already said that
you mean now i won't find it here
but there's a guy no jig jig street has
a whole lot of
let me see what he saw got anything that
might interest me
got something that'll keep you hard
looking for something raw don't tell
anyone okay
i'll come back some other time betting
on it
you didn't see nothing all right how
about you you're buying or just gonna
stand there like a pig undercover
do you know looking for bds
a particular kind particular
you a badge give me the best of the best
the ones with the death's head
didn't know i was dealing with a
connoisseur
death's head will cost you though don't
judge me got anything that might
interest me
let you there so
i let me actually sell a bunch of junk
wow 30 bucks amazing how much do i get
for these
99 okay
[Music]
i assume there's no reason to keep these
around
here's here's 50 guns here here you go
so the one i don't need this anymore
this is weak now
but it says are you sure you want to
sell it which makes me think maybe not
that's such a cool gun
oh
where's my butt plugs
you can disassemble guns for crafting oh
got anything that might interest me okay
you can upgrade them all right
well we it seems like we keep finding
[ __ ] all the time
i can't buy i can't buy them back from
him but
oh then there's more they're more
expensive now great
oh i sold my butt plugs are you [ __ ]
kidding me no
give me back
okay so how do i remove the filter
i'm supposed to buy am i supposed to buy
this
yeah pleasure doing biz with you
i got the goods hop in
suck let me get everything prepped you
make sure the wreath snug on you
you'll watch while i edit in real time
no you'll want to
ready when you are
i want you to describe what you see you
might catch something like this
no one else with that kind of fashion
sense ordered recently
heard [ __ ] like that before sounds like
scavs to me
ordinary box decker tanaka
rogers logo standard for
trashy
we need to find out where it was
recorded
ew
we're running out of time here
[Applause]
yuck yucky monkey
all right what am i missing this dude
electric coffee was cold okay
we're looking for an electric core power
plant located near a bucket slice
pizza shares his dna with styrofoam
nobody's gonna slap across town for it
here we go old electric core power plant
in charter hill
gotta make do with this for now nothing
else to garner from this scroll
hell yeah oh no loading okay
no time to lose we got to go there
nice uh let's get going sure let her
in the meantime i can level up my [ __ ]
i think we need to level up like healing
i can only do one
i ain't doing stealth
sure
still can't shake it that virtue sample
we saw with the dead's head moth
all they scroll is snuff then stop it
they'd have to be utter gongs to waste
her on something like that oh
i'll probably do one more mission and
then
we'll chill out what do you mean i gotta
we're talking about
blood whoa what she does but also it's
got a doll's implant
i mean that's not a package you find
lying out in the street
i like the game a lot though
the universe is just so [ __ ] nuts
it makes it fun
oh uh tomorrow i'm joining jack's uh
live stream
uh for red nose day the charity
turn the livestream so that should be
fun check that out
and uh that's where i'm donating
december months
revenue
what time let me look up
let me google that for you
so it's on the 12th but a december 12th
sunday
i thought they told me of the arasaka
towers
we
no it can't the nusa be
and federalists they tell us that
arasaka self-destructed the tower
to prevent militech from seizing the
building and liberating night city
hey if you listen to the story time
zones chris
how the [ __ ] do they work i don't know
when they were losing the battle for
nice city they detonated a nuclear
device in their own hq
[ __ ] park
and
did [ __ ] just call me while i was in
the car
she just called me while i was in the
car
oh sorry
[ __ ] i'm too weak are you serious
ow ow my toes
my [ __ ] toes
all right now we're never going to steal
everyone always gives me [ __ ] for not
stealth thing here we go
all right here here comes the stuff bd
1c1c
yeah did it
okay i didn't do it it looks like i
uh
they can't see me they can't see me they
can't see me
i can't see you didn't see me you didn't
see me but here i am
oh [ __ ] it wasn't me
it was keanu reeves
oh [ __ ] i should not have gotten in
there i didn't realize there was more in
sight
[Music]
instead of master 64.
oh all right here we go first try
gotcha i go here stealth master 64.
chat
staff master 64. you didn't see me
how do i kill
police them
in extreme cases
make one move and you're dead
he breathed
still missed the 64.
try to find a way to the lower level
i can't see a single [ __ ] thing
i am the
ugly dog
[Music]
foreign
did you pick up anymore
i wanna roll everything
hey i stuffed my way there you goddamn
know it
come on
i just went around everything
ow owie my toes
oh
i mean i breached protocol
[ __ ] [ __ ]
[Music]
a master hacker
i told you bro i told you about the
hacks bro
gate open surveillance
off on off [ __ ] coward
hiding like a child
why am i hacking a car why am i hacking
a car bro
i hacked the car
you wouldn't hack a car
master hacker 64.
damn that's a lot of them
heard shots he's still alive i'm here
got no time to creep around
this gun is a beast dude
[Music]
coming through
don't peek
got the blueprint be there in a sec try
to find a way to the lower level
i've infiltrated the system
they didn't see me yet they got no clue
where i am
are you serious i died so [ __ ] fast
[Music]
what
sarah that doesn't count
all right all right all right
let's do it calm way ah let's actually
start let's actually stop this time
heard shots you still alive i'm here
got enough time to creep around
now we're selfing for real
now it's real selfie
[ __ ] sake
what the [ __ ]
i don't think i need to do this
[Music]
one last person came in last time so
annoying all right
i'll be i'll be more careful
got the blueprint be there all right
let's not get killed by the last [ __ ]
again
bro you're the last one alive
thank you thank you thank you
[ __ ] cowards
found a way down you see my position
yep be there in a sec wait for me v hold
up
i'm close i'm here
we need to get to level minus two
haven't really heard something
something wrong relax
[Music]
oh bro you're on fire
oh my god it's dark
quick
you're in the way
[Music]
oh purple
what'd i get there's one more in here
oh come on
nice very nice
sarah defs everyone you're watching them
hard chorus most epic play through
[ __ ]
i feel bad for their heads
they pop like cherries i get it now
holy [ __ ] i finally get it keep going
that's what that means
covers classic can't go wrong
[Music]
all right we're almost there what do we
got that's a maintenance room
[ __ ] this gun plows through them dude
really you're doing the overheat thing
first
[Applause]
nice
i'm innocent i'm innocent
you i'm innocent bro i didn't do nothing
where are you close to the studio i
think
you find anything useful
it's kianu
i popped everyone's cherry yeah i'll
break the link at my end at the same
time
gonna pop her cherry wait
wait what
all right let's do this
wait for my signal here goes yeah
ready yeah and
now i did it
you're welcome
she's fine thank god i saved their life
evelyn i'm a lifesaver people live
thanks to me
i pop their cherries well every single
one of them
oh which way we're getting i sealed the
doors
and managed to power the elevators
elevators it is then
what's up keanu how you doing we got a
hat
dude we got so many items
that was an elevator this whole time
we did it hell yeah
come on please
just what for me
no flipping weight smoking is and it
stinks too
say whatever the [ __ ] you want but just
light up
no non-smokers are the [ __ ] worst
just my luck smokers are for posers
we going in
what's there to wait for didn't go
through hell and back just to stand in
front of a door
i can't stop playing
she's sleeping uh where am i
uh at least i think she is her eyes are
closed and she's not shaking anymore
still no pants huh
i would have already killed her by now
if i didn't feel so bad for her
you're mad at her why
when you asked me to scour her
behavioral chip i was just about
done dealing with your [ __ ] judy i
didn't have
i know it's okay so i don't get why
you'll find out in a sec whoa what the
[ __ ] is that
okay show me give me a sec while i set
the parameters
guess we'll find out if our doll really
did lose her tune
come on v thanks keanu
okay that gun is insane
but what else did we get oh
purple gun purple gun
yeah attachments
so we have two which one do more this
one did more
i just want to look at this one cause it
looks [ __ ] nuts
oh they don't like me right now i'll be
the first to admit
this does not look good
touch
oh my god chill bro well now
look at you
hey i should have started with that
you need anything i probably should have
put on pants for this i'm not here to
nag
just talk
all right
it's that time of the day thanks for
joining the stream i had a lot of fun
hope you guys did as well
very nice i'll see you tomorrow with
another fresh
fresher roo yay
i like him i go bang bang and shoot and
kill people for no reason it's fun
that sounds weird anyway profess
yay see you guys